Botschafter und
angesehene Delegierte der Weltführer Vor einem Jahr
stand ich zum ersten Mal in
dieser großen Halle vor Ihnen. Ich sprach die Bedrohungen an,
denen unsere Welt ausgesetzt ist, und ich präsentierte eine
Vision, um eine bessere Zukunft für die
gesamte Menschheit zu erreichen. Heute stehe ich vor dem
General der Vereinten Nationen  Assembly, um
die außergewöhnlichen Fortschritte zu teilen, die wir in
weniger als zwei Jahren gemacht haben. Meine Regierung
hat mehr erreicht als fast jede andere
Regierung in der Geschichte unseres
Landes. Amerika
hat diese Reaktion also nicht erwartet, aber das ist in
Ordnung